we're talking about clowns judges on an
employment tribe bill in the uk ruled
today that it's sexual harassment to
mock a man for being bald
electrician tony finn claimed unfair
dismissal from his job because he said
he was subjected to discrimination for
having no hair specifically his factory
supervisor jamie king called him a bald
bleep
incredibly he won the case because the
judge has determined that hair loss is
much more prevalent amongst men than
women so using it to describe someone is
a form of discrimination they said in
our judgment there is a connection
between the word bald on the one hand
and the protected characteristic of sex
on the other what are they talking about
even
even more absurdly the judges compared
being mocked about boldness to remarking
on the size of a woman's cleavage
raising a previous case where a man was
found to sexually arrest a woman by
commenting on the size of her breasts
you might be unsurprised to hear that
all three judges on this panel who reach
this decision are themselves bald
you might also be unsurprised to hear
that i think their judgment is
hair-wrenchingly ridiculous there's
something sexual about being bald
no bald man's ever been wolf versus on
the street or objectified in the office
by a leering woman saying that's a hot
shiny dome you got there darling
being bold is just a fact of life not a
topic for sexual harassment lawsuits
although perhaps i have to consider i
may have got all this wrong because when
i sent this story to my family what's
that group this morning my sister
pointed out that our follicly challenged
brother jeremy has always claimed that
his bald head is a solar panel his words
for a sex machine
that's quite correct he replied to the
group chat and why i need to be kept out
of the sun
incidentally my brother jeremy retired
as a british army colonel today after 37
years of outstanding service to his
country including numerous war zones i
got the hair but he got the balls calvin
klein has launched the campaign to as he
as it puts it celebrate the diversity of
families the ad went viral on social
media it shows roberto bette a pregnant
trans man is about to give birth to her
baby noah along with her partner erica
fios a transgender woman calvin klein
said today in support of women and
mothers around the world we highlight
the reality of new families
i don't want to think about this i don't
have a single anti-trans sentiment in my
body i believe in fairness and equality
for all trans people
for calvin klein to put that out uh to
say they're supporting women and mothers
really is that what you're doing when
you're doing that or are you potentially
exposing the trans community to
unnecessary mockery i'm not sure how
many trans people will look at that
campaign and think that is good for the
transgender cause or the transgender
community and that's all i want
companies like calvin klein when they do
this virtue they need to think about
think about what you're doing and the
impact it may have because i watched
what happened when that went on social
media and immediately lit up with just
widespread mockery and if that's what
you want to achieve fine i don't think
it is
and that's why i think these things are
problematic that's not really about
women and mothers is it it's a very
tough time right now for many millions
of people around the world as rocketing
inflation drives the cost of food fuel
and bills through the roof and as always
when this happens the heaviest burden
falls on those with the smallest
resources the poorest
many get so desperate they rely on
charitable food banks for donations to
make sure that they and their families
simply have enough to eat they don't do
this because they want to
they do it because they have to and the
double whammy of an economy wrecking
pandemic and now ruinous inflation has
led to a massive increase in demand for
those food banks from america to the uk
these are serious times demanding
serious answers from serious people
instead we have politicians like british
conservative mp lee anderson who reckons
he's got it all worked out
i think you'll see first on that there's
not this dude this this massive use for
food banks in this country but
generation after generation who cannot
cook properly they can't cook a meal
from scratch they cannot budget the
challenge is there of course
how stupid of us
that was me thinking people go to food
banks because they're literally
penniless and have no option but
apparently it's because they don't know
how to cook or budget properly
they should simply as he suggests be
sure how to lock out a nutritious meal
he reckons for 30 pence
now in the interest of fairness i
decided to fact-check the anderson with
a bit of consumer research i discovered
you might actually been onto something a
pint of milk five pence a sliced white
loaf of bread ten pence packet of crisps
three pence six eggs eleven pence then i
remembered these were the prices in 1972
50 years ago
to get a little deeper into leander's
political career you'll soon discover
why he might not understand what it's
like to be poor his salary of more than
84 000 pounds is more than double the uk
average he also claimed two hundred and
nineteen thousand pounds of business
costs from twenty twenty to twenty
twenty one uh that's sixteen thousand
pounds more than the average for any mp
life's a lot easier when the taxpayers
stumping up for it isn't it mr anderson
an explosive and shocking video of
broadway legend patti lupone berating a
theater goer has emerged the two-time
tony award winner has seen yelling
furiously the woman in the audience so
what was the crime heckling filming the
performance on her smartphone chatting
to friends maybe doing a tense monologue
oh no far more serious she wasn't
wearing her mask properly
put your mouth over your nose that's why
you're in the theater that is the rule
if you don't want to follow the rule
[Applause]
who do you think you are if you do not
respect the people that are sitting
around your salary
oh the indignant fury but hang on one
sec can we just go back on that again
[Applause]
do not respect the people that are
sitting around you
how weird i think i've spotted a bit of
a problem with her indignant rage it's
called bare face literally hypocrisy
foaming at the mouth in righteous
fury and a woman who's surrounded by
people and masterless while you yourself
are also surrounded by people a maskless
nothing screams absurd liberal coveted
rule hypocrisy than an unmarked singer
spitting abuse and particles of god
knows what and a theater goer who is
doing exactly the same thing that she is
doing in that exact same moment
it's not just delusional divas belting
up mask wearing virtual signals to the
normal people while singing a different
tune themselves we see this hypocrisy
time and again at the moment here's
hillary clinton on twitter
couldn't be clearer and here's hillary
clinton on the red carpet at the met
gala last week
no mask for hillary just for the poor
flunky who's puffing her dress
it's one rule for the funkies one for
the elite well my memo to the masked
mafia is simple
i see you and i see your faces